russia has masked military forces on
ukraine's borders but putin denies he'll
invade his demands are about much more
than ukraine what's going on
putin is holding ukraine hostage he
demands nato never expand to the east
that nato pulled its military forces
from members that joined after the cold
war and that nato never deploys certain
weapons near russia's borders
in return he promises
nothing putin wants to regain control of
ukraine of course
but more than that he wants to destroy
nato
he wants to divide east european members
from their west european allies
to split the us from europe to regain
russian hegemony
those are his real goals in this crisis
he's manufactured
the us must stand by its alliance
commitments
it must stand with ukraine
it must stand with nato
if we give in to putin's demands it will
be open season for aggressive dictators
around the world
it will be disastrous for america
do you think the u.s should stand up to
putin let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei